we have similar pattern from Stanford
University we'll talk about distribution
three models of Social and Information
Network okay thanks super this is joint
work with a bunch of people one of whom
is in the audience you such a jury or
sesh and then also with some my
colleague in math at Stanford Jacob Fox
and several PhD students we should gupta
Fenway and Nicole why okay so
distribution pre models of social and
information network so what do I mean by
social and information networks I just
mean networks where the edges represent
your relationships between people or
and/or the flow of information and so
you're all familiar with lots of
examples right facebook if you want you
can think of it as a graph with the
vertices being the people and the edges
being the relationships you can think
about Twitter and the graph of who
follows whom and so on and so forth so
it's really not much of an exaggeration
to say you know in the 21st century
computer science social network analysis
has been one of the sort of major new
themes that's come up with the past 10
to 15 years sort of systems to have
these big social networks data
collecting them and then studying their
their properties and so there's a huge
community that thinks about social
networks and one thing pretty much
everybody can agree on maybe the you
know the only thing that pretty much
everything everyone can agree on is that
social networks are in some sense
special they have special structure
meaning they're not worse case graphs
they're not arbitrary they have
predictable features that you see over
and over again in different application
domains so it seems to require some kind
of you know special model to capture the
structure of social networks but the
20th century random graph models aren't
good enough so if you look at like
erdos-renyi random graphs they really
don't resemble the accepted qualitative
features of social networks really need
a different model so there's also a
pretty good consensus about what these
high-level predictable features are of
social and information networks so I've
given you sort of a list here so the one
you've maybe heard the most about is a
heavy tail degree distribution for
example like a power law another thing
you hear a lot about you know what makes
social networks special that specialist
community structure so the idea that
they'll have dense subgraphs indicating
a community much more richly connected
internally than externally triadic
closure will have a lot more to say
about that's the property the two hot
paths
and the clothes into triangles or if you
like friends of friends tend to be
friends themselves and then finally
there's the small world property you can
get from anywhere to anywhere else with
a surprisingly few number of hops so
this is sort of the most studied and
most agreed-upon qualitative features of
why social networks are special but once
you actually try to drill down and posit
a specific mathematical model to
articulate this structure all of a
sudden the consensus goes away and
there's literally dozens of different
competing camps so different generative
or probabilistic models meant to suggest
what social networks generally look like
so you know just to give you a sense so
10 years ago there's a nice survey
written by chakrabarti and falou toasts
and back then 10 years ago they singled
out 23 different generative models to
talk about in their survey and compared
along different axes and we see multiple
new models proposed in almost every
month so 10 years later there's many
more than 23 and if you think about it
this sort of poses a challenge to doing
theory which is relevant to social and
information networks because it's really
not clear which you know if any of these
models one should believe and it's not
like things are going toward consensus
right the physicist sort of had their
favorite models computer scientists have
their favorite models so it seems like
you know we're going to be stuck with
this proliferation of generative models
for a while and so when we started you
know when we started this research
project we did want to prove results
about social and information networks
algorithmic results structural results
or we certainly did not want to do was
assume one of these specific
probabilistic models we didn't want to
run the risk of proving results that
were an artifact of the specific
distributional assumptions we wanted to
sort of capture something more
fundamental that's going on no matter
which generative model you believe it so
that naturally led us to the following
research program we said well what's
sort of the intersection of the
properties of all of the generative
models that people ever think about so
what properties does every single you
know motivating a generative model
possess secondly to those minimal
properties alone in the intersection
already already enable any non-trivial
results structural results or
algorithmic results and so really what
we were
to do is have a framework that would let
us prove theorems that would be sort of
relevant simultaneously across any
generative model you might care about
both the ones of today and the ones that
will inevitably be proposed tomorrow ok
so the high-level research program I'm
going to tell you about let me digress
for one slide just to explain how this
sort of connects to the themes of this
week and more generally the special
semester so one of the major themes of
the semester is is beyond worst-case
analysis the idea of proposing
alternative alternatives to worst-case
analysis to get better advice about you
know which algorithm is better than
another one and one of the things we
just worked really well in that field is
something I like to call hybrid models
so for example the whole second half of
my bootcamp tutorial is about hybrid
models and this is a way to combine both
worst case and average case aspects and
so what you do with hybrid models is you
seek out an algorithm which is
simultaneously good for a wide range of
distributions okay so you have in your
mind some class of distributions over
inputs an adversary if you like pics
which distribution from that class
inputs actually being generated from you
don't know which one you have to come up
with an algorithm which is almost as
good as the best for that distribution
no matter what the distribution is and
there's lots of examples of these hybrid
models famous ones you've probably heard
about like smooth analysis semi-random
models prior independent auctions and so
on and really you know this was kind of
you know you could imagine coming up
with our research program without
thinking this way but this was really
the lens through which we were looking
when we formulated these goals we really
sort of it affects wanted to take a
worst-case overall positive generative
models of social networks and have a
single algorithm or a single structural
result which was true simultaneously for
all of those distributions now in the
work i'll describe there aren't actually
any distributions we focus on sort of
deterministic conditions they're going
to hold with high probability and all
these over all the generative models but
this was still kind of how we arrived at
this this line of work okay so we're
going to focus on traffic closures let
me return to that that was the third of
the four properties I listed at the
beginning about what's special about
social networks so again triadic closure
means in social networks to hot path
tend to close in two triangles or if you
like friends of friends
to be friends so this is an old idea it
was popularized in a very influential
paper by the sociologist Mark
granovetter back in 1973 he was
discussed before then as well and it's
easy to sort of tell anecdotes about why
in a social network you probably would
expect actually try that closure so
suppose I tell you the two people are
friends what do you what you know what
what else is probably true well it
probably means they interact with each
other through their mutual friend and
it's much more frequently you're likely
that the linter act and two random
people in the network moreover the fact
that they have a common friend makes it
likely they'll be similar in some sense
like I've shared interests which makes
it more likely they'd want to be friends
with each other or maybe even you know
they feel pressure to be friends because
they don't want to exert any you know
any stress on the friendships they
already have with the common friend so
there's lots of stories about why you
might expect this but those are just
stories but if you go to the data I mean
you really do see plenty of evidence for
this tragic closure property so this is
one plot of one standard social network
but you get similar plots for lots of
other social networks and lots of
different domains so this is the network
of email communications at Enron some
years ago and here's what the plot shows
okay so what I've done is I've bucketed
pairs of vertices of this network
according to how many common neighbors
they have okay so there's some vertices
that have no neighbors in common and
then there's some pairs of vertices that
have lots of neighbors in common so
that's the x-axis the y-axis is in a
given bucket for a given number of
common neighbors what fraction of those
pairs are themselves connected I guess
that's what I'm calling the closure wait
so the fraction it pairs with a given
number of common neighbors that are
themselves connected and what you see is
this very clear trend that as two pasta
two nodes have more and more common
neighbors they're more and more likely
to be directly connected okay now so
what would this plot look like on an
earlier any random graph with edge
density p it look like this yeah
it would be flat ok B flat with a line
at the edge density py edges are
independent all right so conditioned on
the number of common neighbors are to
know that tells you nothing but probably
they're connected is exactly p okay so
this is one of the senses in which areas
rini is really not a good model for the
types of properties you see in actual
social networks okay so somehow we want
to be thinking about graphs whose plots
look something like this so I'm going to
give you two different definitions two
different graph models kind of motivated
by this type of traffic closure property
before I get into those details let me
just spend one slide sort of saying why
did we focus on triadic closure I mean
one reason is just as social networks go
it's it's one of the more
uncontroversial things you could pick to
assume it's pretty contentious it's
basically one of the most universal
signatures of social networks but you're
also you actually you're probably
wondering you know why didn't we talk
about power law graphs which is maybe
the property you hear the most about and
the first reason is just for the types
of problems we were motivated by and
we're really thinking about so the
community tech detection like problems
which is what people tend to obsess over
in social network analysis so things
like then sub graph or kliik assuming a
power law distribution doesn't really
help okay so hard problems remain pretty
hard if all I know about a graph is that
is that it has a power law distribution
okay in this otherwise worst case so as
we'll see in one of our graph classes
you can actually find the maximum clique
in polynomial time and that's certainly
not true none of our results are true
assuming only a power law distribution
so that said so you know the our initial
work was done in 2014 but you know just
this year there's subsequent work which
is showing that at least four other
problems specifically for problems
inside key this actually is an
interesting assumption so you make an
assumption that a graph has a power law
degree distribution no other assumptions
and it turns out with just that
assumption there's lots of graph
problems which you can speed up over the
best algorithm the best running time
known for the worst case ok so at lots
of problems where you need say n squared
on worst case crafts but you can get
much closer to linear assuming only a
power law degree distribution and this
is true for lots of lots of problems
transitive closure matching metric
problems like diameter and radius and so
on so that's been a just interesting
recent really very recent development on
the on the power law degree side but
again for us for the problems we cared
about traffic flow
was the one that had bite was the one
that actually gave you a foothold to
prove interesting results okay so the
rest of the talk i'm going to give you
two different you know so graph classes
that are meant to capture triadic
closure in different ways and for each
one i'm going to highlight one result
that we proved so one structural results
in the first part and when algorithmic
result in the second part so anyone i
want to ask any questions before i get a
little more precise a little more
mathematical yes yeah yeah yeah so far
I've just given you the intuition that
you know if you know the two pairs have
a common neighbor they're more likely in
some sense to be connected than if they
don't the graffiti show before I mean
it's surprising that it's a completely
linear right it is yeah so I picked I
mean a lot of the plots look roughly
like that but i did is sort of
remarkable but we're not going to assume
a linear dependence as you'll see it'll
be easier for it yeah vomited a guy
means at some point there's no more
pairs of nodes with that many
commentators the strength of this
connection because I mean on a suit lot
of people tend to connect to each other
because Facebook suggest stuff but I
mean thank you big question yeah so and
and this is especially relevant cuz I
brought up the the Grand a better paper
and he was really concerned that so the
papers called the strength of weak ties
so he made this distinction between
strong and weak ties which we will not
be making I think that be at a very
interesting direction to take this work
so we're just looking at the binary you
know are they connected or are they not
but you could imagine weights and so on
okay good so triangle dense graph so the
the formal definitions simple enough but
let me just show you a cartoon let me
relate it back to the plot we just saw
of you know the closure rate is a
function of the number of neighbors in
the enron graph so in effect we want a
definition which sort of says like let's
only worry about graphs whose plot looks
something like this but as I was telling
you Oh see you know we don't want to
make a overly restrictive assumption
that would sort of defeat the point so
we're not going to assume like a linear
relationship between the X and the y
axis that would be way too strong so for
the and we're going to so we're going to
sort of
look at two different course innings of
what these plots look like and for the
first one in effect what we're going to
do is rather than bucket pairs of
vertices by their number of common
neighbors we're just going to you know
distinguish between pairs of vertices
with no common neighbors and those that
have one or more common neighbors and
the assumption is going to be on average
over pairs of neighbors that have at
least over pairs of vertices that have
at least one common neighbor you should
see a decent closure rate okay some
parameter T bounded away from zero ok so
imagine we're sort of averaging this
plot all over here and then you know
what's forbidden right so basically we
want graphs whose plot lies in this
green shaded region so what's forbidden
is that pairs of nodes with at least one
common neighbor have a very small
closure rate ok that's the one thing
we're forbidding in this graph class so
NBD let me nearly make it precise though
ok so we make a precise through the
transitivity of a graph so this is an
old notion also called the global
clustering coefficient and so this is a
number between zero and one and it's
just the fraction of the two hot paths
in the graph that actually are in
triangles okay that are filled in all
right so formally you look at three
times the number of triangles over the
number of not necessarily induced to hot
paths the three is because each triangle
contributes three different two hot
baths okay so for example if you have
like clicks or unions of clicks every
two hot path is filled in right so that
would be transitivity one and it's easy
to see the converse okay the only way to
have transitivity one is to be the
disjoint union of clicks the path
nothing's filled in so that would be
transitivity zero and more generally any
bipartite graph would have transitivity
zero ok so the graph class we're going
to be talking about which going to be
parameterized by this transitivity but
loosely speaking we think of an infinite
family of graphs we call a triangle
dense if the transitivity of the graphs
is bounded away from zero even as the
graph size grows large okay so you have
to choose you know what is the threshold
you have to choose what transitivity
you're setting as the lower bound so
there's one parameter in this in this in
this definition okay let's say you know
point one or something like that you
insist that the transitivity stays
bounded above point one even as the
graphs crow or
fairly large that's me the first graph
class triangle dense graphs okay alright
so a few questions you know so you know
whenever you put down a definition
you've got a lot of work to do
justifying your existence by this
definition not some other one so first
of all okay so the real social networks
actually satisfy this property dude are
they triangle dense so you know in an
impressive feat of engineering you
gander at all actually computed the
transitivity of the facebook graph and
they found it was point 16 you see that
you might be wondering okay is that a
big number or a small number how should
I interpret that and so help interpret
it let's remember we're talking about
quite sparse graphs so this is a graph
whose edge density is less than like 10
to the minus 5 so a random graph with
this edge density would have
transitivity only 10 to the minus 5 or
less we're seeing more than four orders
of magnitude higher transitivity in the
facebook graph so that's a pretty strong
strangle density and you can do the same
exercise with other social networks and
you get the same kind of thing so at
least you know for you know constants
you know so you know bound it away from
from from 0 it does seem like real
social networks satisfy this definition
so that's great so what can we say about
them so for this I just out you know the
main result of this first doc is going
to be structural and the only point of
the main point of the structural theorem
is to help us kind of understand or
visualize what these triangle dense
graphs look like in some sense and so
the kind of you know inspirations I have
in mind here are like separator theorems
for planar graphs they kind of say you
can more or less think about a planar
graph as a grid generalized grid or like
the regularity lemma which base is a way
of saying you can think about dense
graphs is basically being like random
graphs so how should we think about
these tribal dense graphs well so one
sort of starting point would be to
remember what we said that the
transitivity is equal to one if and only
if the graph is a disjoint union of
clicks so you might hope for like a
robust version of that statement saying
that the transitivity is high if and
only if it roughly looks like an
approximate union of clicks okay so
maybe they're not totally disjoint maybe
they're not totally clicks but this is
sort of what we have in mind is a
hopeful
the canonical triangle dense graph then
you start playing around with the
definition and you realize it's actually
a very weak condition so you realize is
actually some pretty weird graphs which
have high triangle density okay so we're
really not assuming that much one simple
one would be take a click on say root n
vertices and then attach a really long
path to it say with like n vertices ok
so the triangle density of this graph is
very close to 1 because almost all of
the two hot paths are in the klique but
almost all of the nodes are in this long
path which doesn't resemble social
networks at all ok so triangle density
even very close to one can allow for
pretty weird graphs and if you work
harder it gets weirder as well ok so
what's the upshot well I've argued that
having high transitivity it's a
necessary condition to be a plausible
social network so if something's a
social network it will have decent
transitivity but the converse doesn't
seem to hold ok it's not it's not
sufficient to look like a social network
you have non social networks that happen
to have high triangle density so and
this is both you know a bug and a
feature you know the fact that the
conditions so weak if we can prove any
positive results whatsoever they kind of
are immediately meaningful it has a
worst-case flavor right so if we could
prove anything positive it'll hold for
any plausible social network I think of
any plausible social network has high
transitivity and it's also going to
apply to any graph which has high franza
tivity for whatever reason even if it
has nothing to do with social networks
ok so positive results automatically
robust and meaningful but of course the
worry is that the conditions so weak
just nothing interesting is true and
again you know sort of a cautionary tale
would be the power law distribution
doesn't actually help us prove anything
interesting for the kinds of results
that we were looking for ok so the good
news is you can prove some stuff about
triangle dense graphs so assuming
nothing more than a constant fraction of
the two hot paths are filled in so there
was only a highlight is a decomposition
theorem which again will sort of it will
make an it will make precise the idea
that triangle dense graphs are more or
less like the Union approximate union of
approximate clicks now from that
lollipop graph we know when you
to be a little bit careful with how we
make the statement that some statement
of this form is going to be true
intuitively where the theorem is going
to say it's going to say that in a graph
with high transitivity you can cover
kind of most of the interesting stuff in
the graph with dense you know tightly
knit clusters dense tightly knit
clusters okay you can cover most of the
interesting stuff with disjoint tightly
knit clusters may be more precise so
give me a graph with healthy triangle
density I'm going to find a collection
of disjoint induced subgraphs i want to
emphasize these sub graphs are not a
partition in general of the vertices
they only cover part of the vertices in
general but they're going to be disjoint
each of these induced subgraphs is a
tightly knit cluster in the sense that
it has radius at most two in the sense
that it has constant edge density and
constant triangle density where the
constants here depend on the
transitivity in the original graph g now
this by itself is still not non-trivial
because i could just take you know the
empty the empty collection so to make it
non trivial I'll insist that a constant
fraction of the interesting stuff in the
graph actually shows up is preserved in
one of these dense subgraphs we're going
to identify the interesting stuff in the
graph with the triangles of the graph so
a constant fraction of the triangles of
the graph have to show up in one of
these clusters that's the sense in which
you cover most of the interesting stuff
at the graph so for example with that
lollipop graph right so what's the
decomposition going to look like it's
just going to be the klique ok you're
just going to throw out the path
remember you don't have to cover all the
vertices you just cover the klique and
then you're actually going to preserve a
hundred percent of the triangles in the
graph ok so that's the statements let me
help you interpret this a little bit so
why is this interesting I mean so one
reason it's interesting is what we said
it helps us think of triangle dense
graphs as roughly a union of clicks and
so there's a couple other implications
and I one of time to really delve deep
into these let me just say a few words
so first on a conceptual level remember
way back at the beginning of the talk I
listed those four features of social
networks the third one was try at a
closure the second one was commute
structure so a consequence of this
theorem says that those two things are
really not independent properties if you
have triadic closure properties in the
form of a decent-sized transitivity it
is inevitable you will have some
community like structures you will have
Denslow radius subgraphs namely the ones
that are output by our decomposition so
you can think of it as a sort of local
to global results so you make this logo
local assumption just on two hot paths
and yet implies a sort of more global
property of having this collection of
dense sub graphs so you can also you
know as you'll show you a bit about the
proof and you'll get the sense that the
proof is also an efficient algorithm and
we've implemented the algorithm and even
if you implement it literally
unoptimized immediately from the paper
you get pretty decent results or runs
pretty fast and it's useful in various
heuristics so on the theory side you can
do things like recover planted
clusterings in the approximation stable
model balkan bloom and gupta and then
empirically we have used it for
heuristics on various problems on social
networks like for example sampling and
counting clicks okay so these are the
some of the things that the theorem can
be used for but what I want to focus on
on the rest of this first part of the
talk is a little bit about the proof so
any questions about this statement first
yeah but when you say that it gives
community like structure is only does if
there is a small number of sub graph I
mean what if there are many you know I
can maybe the structures that you get
out of this year I mean or the triangles
but yeah I mean in social network
analysis it's pretty common that the
communities people find are small so the
regime of having a linear number of
constant size communities is actually
you know one of the dominant paradigms
in actual social network analysis this
is not this really very it's a very
different regime than like planted by
section and where you have two groups
you know that are sort of sparsely
connected and yeah if you're just you
know if you're talking about Democratic
and Republican blogs okay that's one
case where it makes sense to have two
communities but most social network
analysis actually the relevant cases a
lot of small communities so it doesn't
you know as far as we were concerned
that didn't bother us we agree she
viewed it as a feature to have small
communities yeah
other questions yeah so by extend what
would you mean does it edge speed up
somewhat that's unclear we were thinking
mostly about community detection
algorithms I mean once you have a graph
class it becomes a playground so you can
take your favorite computational problem
and see what is easier on this graph
class we haven't really done that
systematically and again in this part
i'm going to focus on a structural
result not an algorithmic result
questions so in the second part will be
talking about queex I mean for now you
know the statement of the theorem
doesn't mention communities right so
this is sort of an interpretation and
it's in quotes on purpose so you know
there's lots of standard ways to define
communities like through conductance I'm
not going to need any definitions the
community because again my theorem just
says so the theorem I'm not really in
the theorem I'm not asserting semantics
really to these clusters you get out it
seems likely that in most social
networks that are going to correspond
the communities but that's not what
we're proving we're just proving that
there are these dense structures that
capture all the triangles the graph most
of the triangles the ground song all the
community is undefined
yep assuming a property that you assume
for any sub graph this is too strong
this is like like you can assume that
the other than write it so we explored
that it doesn't help that much actually
so I mean it does rule out some of the
particular rogues gallery examples that
I showed you which is why we looked at
it but as far as the strength of the
theorems we can prove it didn't actually
help us but you know and it may be you
know it may still help and we just
haven't figured out how to use it but as
far as we could tell for our theorems it
didn't really buy us much more it's good
question yeah yeah definitely
okay so let me say a little bit about
the proof / algorithm how it works so
the algorithm interleaves two different
subroutines and the first subroutine is
driven by an ocean called the Jaccard
similarity of an edge and Jaccard
similarity is just measuring how much
overlap there is between the
neighborhoods of the two endpoints of an
edge so here's an edge UV there are
seven vertices that are neighbors of at
least one of you or V two of them are
common neighbors that's two out of seven
that's two Jaccard similarity okay so
it's just the fraction of the overall
neighbors that are common neighbors it's
a number between zero and one okay and
so intuitively if an edge is
participating in lots of triangles
that's you know going to be highly
correlated with having high Jaccard
similarity not participating in
triangles is going to be correlated in
some sense with low Jaccard similarity
so the cleaner subroutine what it does
is it just gets rid of edges with low
Jaccard similarity okay less than some
parameter epsilon weak epsilon to be a
constant fraction of the graphs
transitivity okay so while there's an
edge with small Jaccard similarity
delete it or an arbitrary one and repeat
until you're left with a graph where
everything has high Jaccard similarity
okay so that's the cleaner all right all
right so for example on the lollipop
graph what does this good what is this
was the cleaner going to do well these
edges have Jaccard similarity one so
it's not going to do anything here these
edges have Jaccard similarity zero
because there's no common neighbors so
the cleaners just going to rip off this
whole path which is actually exactly
what we want it to do all right in fact
the cleaner alone on some of the
networks we looked at already gives
pretty interesting decompositions but
for the theorem will need a second
subroutine as well all right so what do
you so we have to prove about the
cleaner you just have to prove that you
haven't made the theorem impossible so
the theorem is asserting you better be
preserving a constant fraction of the
triangles so we better not have deleted
all the triangles when we deleted these
edges so why didn't we well the graph
has constant transitivity so that
actually gives us a relationship between
the number of two hot paths and the
number of triangles they're related by a
constant factor on the other hand if an
edge has low Jaccard similarity it means
that edge participates in many more open
to ha paths
then it does triangles so when you
delete an edge with low Jaccard
similarity maybe you delete a few
triangles but you delete way more to hot
paths because to our paths are triangles
are in this constant factor relationship
this can't go on very long and you'll be
left with the constant fraction of the
triangles just you need a lower bound on
the transitivity yeah
okay so why do we do this well once all
edges have decent Jaccard similarity the
graph has some nice properties okay so
first of all its immediate that it's
sort of locally approximately regular so
if you look at any edge and you look at
its two endpoints their degrees can't be
that different only by a factor of 1
minus epsilon just because if your
degrees you know if your neighborhoods
have radically different sizes than the
over the overlap just can't be that big
you can't have high Jaccard similarity
so lemma 2 is immediate and then limit 3
is some simple algebra that I'll spare
you from the lemma 3 already says at
this point we know there are dense
substructures in fact take any vertex
look at its neighbors look at this one
hot neighborhood already it's one hot
neighborhood is going to be dense in
edges and triangles so constant density
where the constant depends on the
transitivity of the original graph ok
and now it kind of seems like hopefully
we're done right so we've identified you
know where these clusters come from you
just get the jacquard similarities hi
you look at in a one-hop neighborhood
you rip it out the obvious thing to do
is now just go back and forth rip out a
one-hop neighborhood clean again rip out
another one hop neighborhood and so it
seems like we get the decomposition so
what could go wrong well the same thing
we were worried about with the cleaner
what could go wrong as we destroy too
many triangles but in this case actually
the fear is real okay it can actually
happen this algorithm actually doesn't
satisfy the theorem and the bad example
is a complete tripartite graph ok so the
complete tripartite graph every Edge has
pretty high Jaccard similarity but
imagine you just ripped out this bottom
left vertex and it's one hot
neighborhood notice it's one hot
neighborhood is all of these vertices
and all of these vertices well you'd
preserve some triangles right so you'd
rip out this neighborhood in any
triangle which involves this lower lever
Tex that would be preserved in the one
hot neighborhood you rip out but you
would be destroying every other triangle
every triangle that involves any of the
rest of the vertices on the northwest
corner ok so that's what happens so you
remove it all the triangles are gone and
you don't preserve the interesting stuff
at the graph so this isn't this is sort
of a natural attempt but it's not quite
enough
happily is a pretty simple fix actually
so this scheme was still more or less
work but we have to supplement the one
hop neighborhood with some additional
vertices from the two hop neighborhood
okay so we pick a vertex we add in all
the neighbors of that vertex and we had
a few neighbors of neighbors and we
choose the set of neighbors of neighbors
to add exactly so that we get the
property that we want where the number
of triangles that we preserve is at
least a constant fraction of the number
of triangles that we destroy now it's
not at all obvious is that there's
always a way to do this okay that there
exists a subset of the two hop
neighborhood so that you actually
destroy or preserve roughly as many
triangles as you're destroying I think
that's the most unintuitive part of the
proof so you really have to prove that
but it is true and moreover it's just a
simple greedy algorithm can be used to
identify the vertices in the two-out
neighborhood that work alright so that's
the final algorithm which gives you the
decomposition theorem you clean get the
Jaccard similarity is up to epsilon pick
an arbitrary vertex go to the one hot
neighborhood supplement it with a few
vertices from the two hot neighborhood
extract clean again extract again and so
on and so that's what leads to this
result if you instead of doing like the
field go back to the other side yeah
instead of doing the charging just took
the better of the one vertex or the
entire set of all the vertices that you
would be deleting together with it with
dad so you're proposing a specific way
of choosing some of the two hot
neighborhood is that right I i think
what i'm saying is instead of deleting
the two op neighborhood part of the two
honey bread yeah just take the entire to
op neighborhood and if like leading it
would have been bad then taking all of
it should be good does that make sense
what's the intuition um sorry I don't
have good intuition about whether it's
true or false triangles yeah then you
should have a lot of triangles and
what's sure i guess the worry is it then
at the next boundary you again have
still more triangles between the two hop
and the three hot neighborhood yeah
which is why it's not obvious you can do
this at all so it's this is kind of the
magical part of the proof that there is
a magical subset of the two op
neighborhood that you don't have this
problem okay that you really get parity
between what you're saving and what
you're destroying okay so that was the
decomposition theorem and that was the
that was the first part of the talk any
any questions so what is the running
time of the algorithm that builds in the
composition yeah so we can do it in time
proportional to the number of two hot
paths in the graph so the number of
wedges in the graph and the property
itself doesn't give you a better
boundary sorry the property itself hi hi
triadic closure right right i mean you
could imagine optimizing it but as
stated you know it doesn't amurri tall
the wedges in a graph and if it happens
to be a cleek then that's going to be a
lot of wedges now in the actual you know
and the actual real social networks that
we look at the number of wedges is not
that big I mean it's superlinear but sub
quadratic you know thinking into the 1.5
or something like that so on them on the
motivating examples it's actually quite
fast is joined to hop that
is proportional to the number of
disjoint to no no just to our paths yeah
so yeah I mean it could be n cubed but
in the motivating example is it tends to
be more like n to the 1.5 yeah and you
know you know Andy was to say we didn't
spend energy on optimizing the running
time so we really went for the really we
actually proved the theorem and then we
realized it's an algorithm and it was
one of those very happy cases where the
algorithm in your proof actually just
works pretty well I'm sure you could do
better by actually you know trying to do
good algorithm engineering we haven't
done that elections um so when you say a
constant fraction of the travel to
preserve this constant could be very
small I say one percent sure potentially
we're throwing out ninety-nine percent
of the graph in theory go do you have a
sense of infectious yeah so in practice
the numbers we capture somewhere between
60 and 90 percent of the triangles
depending on which data set you look at
trying to you know narrow the gap
between the worst case the theoretical
guarantees and what we see on the real
data sets is an open question I mean
you're right so the the the specific
quantitative bounds you get out of this
theorem are not as good as you'd like ok
so the dependence of these constants is
polynomial on the transitivity that you
assume but it's pretty high degree
polynomial I mean one of them is even
quartic in the transitivity we suspect
the right number is between two and
three if you make no assumptions other
than triangle density we think you
really do need at least a quadratic
degradation in terms of the transitivity
if you make more assumptions it's
totally possible you could prove
stronger results are easier to solve
using this decomposition and then divide
and conquer yeah so as far as theorems
about that that's more the subject of
the second talk so I'll show in a
different graph class we can compute
maximum clique simponi meal time so here
the theoretical guarantee we can prove
is not in a worst-case model but in the
approximation stable model of bulk and
Blum and gupta where they positive
ground truth clustering and so in that
case we can prove we can sort of match
their theoretical guarantees using this
algorithm about recovering clusterings
up to small classification error and
then heuristic alee it works well for
some other problems but we don't have
two theorems
like for counting the number of clicks
or even max cut this kind of thing but
you know for the first part I really
wanted I think the you know the one I
wanted to highlight was a structural
result the second part will be an
algorithmic result so it's largely wide
open to just you know once you again
once you have a graph class it's sort of
a fun playground for anyone who does
algorithms right so whatever your
favorite problem is you can start
thinking about it in that class what's
the intuition for that finding a pine
tree and then doing good for hmm that
would be cool yeah we will be internal
tsp I mean we really we haven't done
like I said we haven't done sort of a
systematic exploration of tons of
computational problems in these classes
I think that's a totally worthy thing to
do but we haven't done that we just sort
of focused on our community detection
related problems greater on ESP from
like a different decomposition select
kind of degrees is coming up with this
click decomposition
questions can you just repeat questions
of you yes I'm terrible at that so I'll
try to remember yeah so that I mean that
you know this question is sort of
generally about kind of which
algorithmic problems are easier to solve
in triangle dense graphs and so I just
talked about we have some theoretical
results we have some empirical results
but it's largely open so we focused on
the structural results here okay so let
me talk a little bit about our second
graph class which we call see closed
graphs so going back to the motivating
plot so again you know this was our
Enron network and it was showing them
the closure rate increases with a number
of common neighbors so again we want to
look at some sort of coarser version of
saying we want want grass where the plot
looks like this and so we're just going
to have a threshold okay so that's going
to be the parameter C and in this graph
class we're going to insist we're going
to insist that whenever to a pair of
nodes has at least see common neighbors
they themselves have to be connected so
in other words the closure rates is a
hundred percent from C onward okay so
this is obviously a little bit of a
caricature of what's true in real
networks I mean this gets pretty large
but it's not a hundred percent but you
get a really nice crisp graph class if
you actually just with just a single
parameter with the sea close definition
okay so we're saying that the grat the
we're looking at graphs whose plot lies
somewhere in this green region we don't
care about the closure rate below see
but it better be a hundred percent after
so again graph is C closed if whenever
you have a pair of vertices with C or
more common neighbors they're connected
by an inch
me whatever you want yeah i mean i'll
talk more about how to think about see
but you know c equal to is already
interesting as we'll see so so you want
to think about c is like a constant less
than 10 but the results don't really
need that yeah okay so you can also
think about see close graphs in terms of
forbidding forbidden sub graphs on
indeed if you go back to grant evaders
paper you know he even talks about
triadic closure in terms of what he
calls forbidden triads so for us for c
close graphs what's the corresponding
forbidden subgraphs well they look like
this so what's not allowed is to have
two vertices with no edge between them
with a shared neighborhood of C or more
vertices okay we don't care about how
these are internally connected but if
you have this structure then you're not
a see closed graph okay so that's
another way to think about it alright so
getting back to commissioners question
of you know what kind of see should we
think about so notice the bigger we take
see the weaker the condition were
imposing okay that's sort of raising the
threshold before any constraint kicks in
so the most restrictive class is one
closed graphs once you go to n closed
graphs you get all graphs it's not a
restriction at all okay so one closed
grass they're actually not that
interesting right so that says whenever
you have at least one common neighbor
you have to be connected so that just
says every two hot path closes to a
triangle same thing as transitivity one
that's just the union's of clicks so the
first non trivial thing to think about
would be the family of two closed graphs
and again you know like with triangle
density I mean this is this is a weak
enough condition that you start getting
some graphs you kind of weren't maybe
hoping for but they show up anyways sort
of unannounced and unwelcome so for
example imagine you have a high growth
graph by high i mean like five okay well
if you have a growth at least five there
is no pair of nodes with two common
neighbors if their warrior would give
you a four cycle so the hypothesis of
the the condition just holds vacuously
alright so for example bounded degree
expanders are already members of the two
closed family all right so that's a
little scary right we know lots of
problems kind of the hard cases
expanders so since there's lots of
problems where this is
assumption by itself won't help you but
again we were really thinking about
community detection type problems and in
particular you know things like finding
dense subgraphs finding clicks and
notice actually this this does this
shouldn't bother us if we're trying to
compute gleeks the clique problem is not
a hard problem in a high-growth graph
all right the clique is just an inch
that's the next week okay so it still
raises hope then maybe there are
problems we care about that you could do
something on C close graphs and we can
as i mentioned i'm going to show you we
can actually solve click in polynomial
time for any fixed see okay so we're
actually going to do something more
general we're going to show how to
enumerate all maximal cliques of a/c
closed graph in polynomial time and so
the way and so really this just boils
down to bounding the number of different
maximal cliques in a graph it's been
known for a long time that you can just
enumerate maximal cliques of any graph
in time polynomial in the number of
maximal cliques so if you only have a
small number of clicks you actually can
enumerate all of them in polynomial time
now of course you know you can't stall
click in general and in general graphs
you might have a lot of maximal cliques
and the canonical example here is the
moon moser graph so this is just an n
over 3 bipartite graph so I take a bunch
of triples of vertices and I connect
each pair of vertices which are in
different triples okay so it's like a
bunch of independent sets of size 3 and
then everything else is connected so if
you think about it you get a maximal
clique by just making one choice from
each of the N over three triples so
that's 3 to the n over 3 different
maximal cliques each of size exactly n
over 3 okay and there's a nice theorem
of moon and moser a half-century-old
which actually says this is the largest
number of maximal cliques you can ever
have as a function of the number of
vertices n okay now this doesn't
immediately stymie our goal of solving
cleek and final time because these moon
mozar graphs if you think about it
they're not see closed for any
reasonable seat if you take two
different vertices in a common triple if
n minus three common neighbor is yet
they're not connected by a niche okay so
it's definitely not see closed for
reasonable see other hand this does sort
of you know show us the best we can hope
for
you know just by considering moon Moser
graphs on C vertices which are trivial
ec closed it does show that the number
of maximal cleats in a sea closed graph
might can scale exponentially in this
parameter seat in your threshold c okay
so if there's going to be a positive
result it's going to have a fixed
parameter tractable flavor okay with the
number of maximal cliques well
exponential and c is polynomial and the
other parameters describing the graph
okay and that's in fact exactly what we
show so we show that in every see closed
graph the number of maximal cliques is
at most n squared times exponential and
see that same moon moser three to the
three to the sea over three except with
the n replaced by sea okay so in
particular you can enumerate and
therefore find the maximum clique for
any constancy even for see all the way
up to logarithmic okay so we have a
quadratic dependence on the number of
vertices we know it has to be at least
end of the three halves we're pretty
curious where it is in between we don't
know yet but at the very least you get
this fixed parameter tractable like
upper bound okay so I want to say a
little bit about the proof and then
we'll be done any questions about the
result well so the question is really
are they close to being see closed yeah
so that that's the next step to do yeah
I mean you know I showed you that plot
you know which says that the closure
rate does get pretty high once he gets
reasonably large but you know if you
think about it I mean it you know so
we've it's a nice algorithmic problem
actually suppose I give you a network
and I let you add or delete edges and
you want to make it see closed for some
target see you know how many edges are
what's the minimum number of edges
needed to do that let's presumably an
np-hard problem we haven't proven that
that's presumably not be hard but that's
so we're trying to actually think about
heuristics for approximating distance to
the family of see close graphs well
that's the question the question is not
our real glass see closed no because one
hundred percent is too strong so I mean
so that's one way of doing it also you
know I'm optimistic you could have
robust versions of these theorems saying
if you're close to see closed maybe you
can't compute a click maybe you can
commute a dense sub graph which is
almost as big as the biggest clique or
something like that so say a by criteria
result coming from a weaker assumption
those are all I mean this is ongoing
work so it's stuff we haven't gotten to
yet that's a good question yeah to add
the minimum number of edges to get out
or delete okay just a date what the
heading is not hard yeah that's right so
which is one measure you could use so
that would be interesting actually just
how many edges get added when you do a
sort of close it completion on real
social networks so thanks for the
suggestion I might have an undergrad do
that this is because up there please
like basically on the frosh that video
yes so ignoring ignoring the end okay so
so you know we know there's a lower
bound which scales at least like this
sit again is quick factor yeah then we
know it has to scale like this yeah
dependents on end we don't fully
understand but it definitely does have
to be dependence on n also you do know
that yeah
so I'm going to Talon but let me just
maybe give you a quick kind of picture
of at least parts of the proof this is
going to be kind of very high level in
the interest of time but it's to give
you the flavor of it so it's an
inductive argument ok so this bound
comes out of recurrence the recurrence
has two terms let me just kind of flash
pictures about what each of the two
terms come from so for the purposes of
induction pick your graph G your C
closed graph pick your favorite vertex V
I don't care which one and these are the
vertices connected to V its neighbors X
these are the vertices not connected to
V it's non neighbors ok and so what
we're going to do is we're going to
count maximal cliques in this graph in
two steps so first we're going to delete
V and use induction to compute the
number of maximal cliques in G minus V
so I'll skip that case that's sort of
the easy case and so then the second
case is we have to count the maximal
cliques in G that we haven't counted in
the inductive step when we project it
down into G minus V okay and basically
what can go wrong the reason you haven't
counted all of the cliques is because if
you start with a maximal clique in G and
you look at its projection after
deleting v ok so you've taken a click
you've deleted a vertex in that smaller
graph you know it's a klieg you delete a
vertex from click you get cleek but just
because you started with a maximal
clique in g doesn't mean you have a
maximal clique in the projection ok
Angie minus V it might be that after
deleting v you can take the rest of the
klique and supplement it into a bigger
creek using vertices of X ok so that's
why you need a second case that's why
the induction inductive hypothesis
doesn't do all the work for you so in
the second case we don't use the
inductive hypothesis we actually use the
C closed hypothesis this is where we use
it and let me just tell you the key
property it gives you so basically we
want to bound the number of green
diamonds that can ever show up and we
can do that because the degree of any
vertex and X 2 n is small let me explain
why that's from the sea closed property
I claim that for any vertex and X it has
at most c minus 1 neighbors in n.y well
X is a non neighbor of V V and X are not
connected
these neighbors are all of n okay so X
can have at most c minus one common
neighbors with v because this edge is
missing and it's C closed so that means
it has at most degrees C minus 1 into n
so that lets you that lets you basically
project onto these neighborhoods apply
the moon moser theorem which bounds from
above the maximum number of maximal
cliques in any graph with n vertices
here we're using it on sub graphs that
have c vertices and then you add up over
all the choices of x and that's what
gives you the rest of the second step so
in the N squared one of them comes from
the fact that in our induction we only
delete one vertex before we induct so
that's one factor of n the second factor
of n is we have to sum over all choices
of X when we're bounding the police here
so I'll leave you with a slide with some
open questions and you know so I've
offered you a couple definitions of sort
of new graph classes new playgrounds
motivated by this triadic closure
property and you know if you like these
specific definitions that's great I
think there's tons to do here especially
as some of the questions suggested more
algorithmic applications I think in
general you're going to need stronger
assumptions extra assumptions to make a
lot of progress here but I think there's
tons of work to do but you know even if
you don't like the specific definitions
that I put forth that's fine but i hope
you sort of get the higher-level point
which is that I think there's a
tremendous opportunity for combinatorial
type people like most of the people here
in this room to do some really high
impact work in this direction right so I
mean social network analysis it's really
been kind of one of the biggest problems
people have thought about in computer
science in the 21st century but for 15
years the narratives been driven totally
by the sort of competition between these
different probabilistic models there's
been almost nothing done on these kind
of more robust results worst case
conditions combinatorial conditions so I
have no doubt that just in this general
idea of sort of non probabilistic models
of social networks is it con more to do
so I hope I see some of that for many of
you in the years to come thanks a lot
stay with up enough question so that
whereas giving yourself so that the
slightest condition feels the some ways
a little mate file item in the following
sense and Hunter okay connected so I
understand right supposing you're able
to somehow get a clean precise little
bigger than C and anybody that connects
to see those there has to connect for
the rest of them to kind of start at
that point you can start grow really
can't like make a mistake add some of
the end you should have had somebody
else because the other guys are going to
connect in they have to connect office
or somehow feel like once you get big
enough you can now go read yep so it's
um has that feel that that's been in a
certain point in the night I agree I
mean you really wanted the maximum and
just not a maximal it's uh it's really
not clear to me how you do it without
the enumeration but you absolute right
this sort of this closure property that
once you have a seed of si si vertices
from any click you can kind of fill it
out very easily
so it's a bit of an open-ended question
usually this triadic closure property we
think of it as having some kind of
social space where right the vertices
are in the metric space and then those
two guys are connected then it means
that they are closer to each other by
the triangle inequality and I was just
wondering whether there is what it is
there is a connection with what you're
doing does this metric space point of
view on one side and yeah that's a good
question I mean you go back to the
original granovetter paper his assertion
is sort of like a week qualitative
version of the triangle inequality which
says if you have two strong ties then
these have to be connected by a weak tie
so it's like a relaxed triangle
inequality of some form a on that any
thought sesh I mean I think in general
if you have to embed these in the metric
space it has to be a high-dimensional
metric space because there are lots of
little community and so if you try to
pack it in a low dimensional space then
you get too many edges well you can
always embed in a low dimensional space
just what kind of embedding are you
looking for when you can always undead I
on dimension 3 that's not difficult but
it's just that the embedding is going to
be very complicated if you're looking
for smooth under do you know something
nice also the way you assign the
neighbors it's completely arbitrary in
CC but she wants something yeah so I
said the hot you know the basic answer
to question is we haven't really thought
about geometry in this context and then
what you know is there any interesting
geometry in these graphs I think it
might be a fruitful case for making
extra assumptions you know in the same
way that like to go beyond the low
diameter property if you want to say a
stronger small world property then you
start then you impose extra sort of an
ambient metric space you know the talk
about kind of short and long-range
connections you can imagine also hear
that somehow imposing an extra metric
space would be a path to strengthen
these conditions to get stronger
algorithm results what we've been taught
okay looks like the speaker and may take
you in